- On this episode NBA
star Mason Plumlee stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 251
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Pretty excited about this
because I'm a huge NBA fan and
we have a real life
NBA player here with us.
Mason Plumlee is here.
I'm gonna give him a second to
tell everybody about himself but
you also are
noticing no phone today.
We've decided to go old
school on The #AskGaryVee Show.
I put out a tweet.
We got some questions.
Andy K, it's your
chance to finally be India.
I'm happy for you.
This is something you've
wanted for three or four years.
I've seen the
notes back and forth.
You know, DRock showed me
a text a couple years ago.
Said something
like, "What the fuck?
"Why does India
always get to do this?"
So this is a big moment
for you as well, my friend.
I'm happy for you.
- [Andy] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Alright, Mason, why don't
you tell the Vayner Nation
a little bit about yourself.
- Yeah.
You know,
obviously I play basketball.
From Indiana originally,
went to high school and
college in North Carolina.
Spent my first two
years with the Brooklyn Nets.
Two years, year and a half with
the Portland Trailblazers and
then I was traded to
Denver February this season.
So, you know, I'm going into
restricted free agency this
off-season so I'm
looking forward to that.
Basketball's my
passion, it's what I do.
It gets me out of
bed in the morning.
I don't have to think about it.
I just love it and I
wouldn't trade it for anything.
So, that's my story
and that's how I'm here.
- Couple things.
Tell me about, so first of all,
being able to do what you love
is like the greatest, right?
- Yeah.
- What outside
of the basketball?
When we start going into the
Mason's sphere of interests
that's out of that.
- Yeah.
- Entrepreneurship,
sci-fi, food.
Give me some context
here and the viewers at home.
- Two things that
I've really been drawn to,
one being real estate.
I've enjoyed different
real estate projects that
I've done with partners.
Did a couple here in
Jersey when I lived in Jersey.
And then some in Washington
state when I lived in Oregon.
So real estate has
been very interesting to me.
- You have like an awesome
business model
figured out, right?
I play in a new
market, buy up. Right?
- Yeah.
- You want to get traded and
do stuff in free agency just to
build your real estate empire.
- No, honestly, you always want
to be the player that's Kobe.
One franchise your whole but if
it doesn't happen why not take
advantage of being all over.
- Pretty cool.
So real estate has
been interesting to you.
- Real estate's
been interesting.
- And fruitful. Right?
- Yeah.
- I'm thinking about
your career and how long
you've been in the league.
The real estate
market has been really
strong during those years.
- Yeah, for sure.
- So what?
You buy things and rent out?
- I've done rehab projects.
I've invested in other people's
projects but then also just
starting to explore development
with a partner that I have.
To me it's I've always wanted to
take advantage of like I have a
window where
I know I have contracts
and money coming in but
NBA you can't
play until you're 60.
- You're not golfin'.
- Right, so there's a finite
time to a career and I want to
take advantage of the earnings
that I have during this time and
put aside some
assets for when I retire.
- And not just earnings, right?
I mean here we are sitting.
Obviously, we got connected
through the inner weavings of
our organization but
you're obviously thinking about,
look, 40 million
people email this place,
"I want to be on the show."
Obviously, not only the dollars
and what you can deploy but
having the platform
of the NBA itself--
- For sure.
- that gives you opportunities.
How are you
thinking about the leverage
of just the awareness of brand?
Are people willing to
say yes to things
while you're in the league?
I think one of the things
that I always tell players,
I started a sports agency
we're starting to rep players.
My brother AJ's running it.
Today's a big day.
We may have one of our
first players ever get drafted.
I tell them, look,
I remember this vividly.
I told a kid
right to his face, I go,
"Look, the only
reason I'm sitting with you
"is you're a New York Jet."
- Right.
- And the Jets are
like my heart and soul.
I'm like,
"If you're a Bronco tomorrow,
"I'm gonna lose your number."
And I actually meant it.
Not like to razz him
because I was tell him
he was acting like a dope.
- Yeah.
- And he wasn't taking advantage
of all the things he could be
taking advantage of.
- Right.
- You also, it's funny
you said North Carolina.
You went to Duke, right?
- Yes.
- (blows raspberry) It's one of
the most popular
colleges in the world.
There's just hundred and
thousands of people that are
ruling the world that are
willing to meet with because you
went to that university.
- Yeah.
- The access is insane.
And I had great veterans when
I came in as a
rookie in the league.
Kevin Garnett
told me, he's like,
"Look, you can
pretty much sit down or
"meet whoever you want to."
He said, "You just have to take
the initiative to reach out to
"'em and they'll take your
call or whatever you want to do,
"they'll at
least listen to you."
- Did he then
punch you in the face?
'Cause he seems like
that kind of character.
- No, yeah but he was right.
And into that point too he also
made the point that he's like,
"Once you're done
playing," he's like,
"they probably
aren't picking up.
"You might not get to sit down.
"You might not get the
return call, whatever."
But he was like,
"Don't wait until you're 40."
He was playing with me when he
was 38 years old but he's like,
"Don't wait 'til you're
40 to pick up the phone,
"to take advantage of
the platform that you have."
- You know it's
funny you just said that.
One of the things that would be
interesting is to think about
not only the real estate
arbitrage when you're in a new
markets but the
social graph, right?
So like, it's kind
of interesting, right?
Like who are the 5 to
25 men and women that you
want to meet when
you're in Portland.
Literally when you get traded
to Denver like is one of the
processes, and this is for all
the aspiring athletes out there
or actual athletes.
You know, okay,
now I'm in Denver.
Like literally, who are the
15 to 25 business or cultural
leaders of Denver that I want
to meet and you pull it off.
- Yeah.
- It's interesting.
Okay. How was Duke?
- Duke was great,
man. I enjoyed it.
I stayed all four years.
Guys don't do that anymore.
I enjoyed it enough to stay.
- You're like a unicorn.
- I know, right?
But no, it was a lot of
fun. Had a great experience.
- Fan base is ridiculous, right?
- Fans are the best.
- What about when
they're pissed at you?
- Yeah, that's hard.
- When they were pissed at you,
were they tough or were they
kinda fully bought in
and they won so much and
you guys have a such a winning.
I always think that
winning organizations
are soft, really.
- Yeah.
- You know?
Like they're winning often,
they could only get.
When I get mad at a Jet player,
I hate them with all my heart
because we haven't won ever.
- Right, right.
- And so I'm like I'm really
fucking pissed at you, dude.
Like I want to win.
Whereas with the
Yankees when I won a bunch,
I'm like yeah,
I'm mad at you but
we won so many championships.
Like no big deal, bro.
- Yeah, well, you know they had
a rough stretch before I got to
school and then the group I was
with my freshman year we won the
championship so it was a good--
- You started off
on the right foot.
- And then it was like the next
three years you're trying to get
back to that and it never
happened so you have to enjoy
the moment and take it for what
it is 'cause it's not guaranteed
to happen again.
You go there one time in your
freshman year and you're like,
"Oh, this is just what happens."
That's not the case.
- Knowing a lot of
my fan base is a mix,
I think some of them may
not know a lot about you.
Tell them a little bit about the
family dynamics that I think are
really intriguing with you.
- Yeah, so I have two brothers
who play in the NBA as well.
I have a little brother with the
New York Knicks and then I have
an older brother with
the Charlotte Hornets.
We all had one year
together in high school,
one year together in college
but those are my best friends.
I think I've alway benefitted
from watching my older brother
go through the same process
that I'm about to embark on.
And then I've been able
to help my little brother,
too so it's been a
great dynamic for me.
And then also I have
a little sister who,
she plays
volleyball at Notre Dame.
And now I'm just like a
cheerleader 'cause I don't know
anything about volleyball.
But I'm happy for her.
- Dude, are your parents like
the greatest
athletes of all time?
- No, they were athletes.
They weren't the greatest but
they would tell you that too.
But we grew up--
- It's crazy to think--
- Yeah.
- like forget about
even having the DNA,
the parenting.
- Mhmmm.
- The serendipity.
- Yeah.
- The great fortune.
- Yep.
- To have three boys in
the NBA is so mind bending.
- Yeah, I mean you
see a lot of brothers,
a lot of twins.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But,--
- [Gary] Three is--
- we're happy that
Marshall joined the NBA family.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The three thing, how
often has that happened?
Three brothers in the league.
- One other time.
- Which was?
- I think it was the Barrys.
- Right. And their dad played.
Right, right.
- Yeah, so.
- That's just insane.
- It doesn't happen that often.
- Do you guys think that
eventually you'll go on the road
like when you're
retired and you'll be all about,
there's something really there.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm serious.
- No, we could
definitely do something fun.
We've always talked about, the
best part about it is spending
our off-season together
and working out together.
So I have my
little brother here,
like I said with the Knicks.
My older brother
likes New York too so--
- You guys are setting
up camp here this--
- Yeah. Pumblee--
- Who's the best player?
- Me. We all say that. So...
- But what's the true answer?
- Me.
- It is, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
I would tell you the truth.
- Yeah, I believe you.
Alright, Andy let's do this.
This is your big moment.
- [Andy] My big moment.
- What's the first question?
- [Andy] Jason Crocker asks,
"Dude dropped 40
points on me in high school.
"How early did you decide to
go all-in on basketball and
"commit you life
to that pursuit?"
- Well, now I have a new
career high in high school.
I didn't know I had 40.
- Do you know what your
career high in high school is?
Of course you do.
- Honestly, I really don't.
- You're that good?
Fuck.
(group laughter)
If my career high was like 17,
I'd be like, seven.
I would know everything.
I'd be like, yeah, this
kid, I crossed him over.
- I have to give a
shout out to Christ School.
I love my high school.
It was a all-boys boarding
school in North Carolina.
But we had such a
good group of guys.
Our first five all
went and played in college.
So it was such a
fun team to be on.
Our goal every year is
like, can we go undefeated.
We never got it, but--
- You weren't one of those guys
that came up in
high school where
you were the guy dropping 64?
- Yeah.
That's funny you asked that.
But I didn't have 40
in a game, but anyway.
For me, it was a
passion early on.
In Indiana,
everybody plays basketball.
- Sure, it's religion.
- Yeah, it is, it really is.
Like Texas and football.
- Are you a Colts fan?
- I am, yeah.
Not a Pacers fan, but Colts fan.
But growing up--
- Oh, why not a Pacers fan?
- You know what, when I first
started watching the NBA,
it was always Utah
and Chicago in the finals,
so I love Chicago.
I watched Jordan all the time.
- So you're a
bandwagon Bulls fan?
- Yeah.
I was northwest Indiana, though,
so I was close to Chicago.
- That's how you
decided to justify that?
- And they were winning.
- I know what they were doing.
Alright, so was it
from birth, you were all in?
- No, I mean, when I was young
and just playing at
recess on the playground
with my brothers--
- Were you always
ridiculously tall?
- No, I wasn't always tall.
And I think that's, in the NBA,
not the NBA but in basketball,
you get the guys who are tall,
so they're like,
"Well, I'll play basketball.
"I'll put this to use."
But it was always a passion of
mine from when I was little.
It's not something
that I decided to do
because I ended up being tall.
- So when did you go all-in?
- All-in?
Honestly, to me
the first, I would say,
business move
concerning basketball
was when I
decided to leave my home
and go to a boarding school.
Because up until
then, I loved it.
I would just go and
play for the fun of it.
- And when was that?
- I did that my
sophomore year high school.
- You have a big freshman year?
- I didn't have a
big freshman year.
I played varsity in JV
at my hometown high school.
- Did you grow in
that summer like a machine?
- No, I was like 6'7",
6'8" in my freshman year.
(Gary laughs)
- I love that he's like,
it's your own reality, right?
He just hangs out with seven
footers all day, I get it.
- Yeah, but to me
I was going all-in
because I didn't,
basketball was for fun.
And that was the first sacrifice
made toward the career.
- [Gary] Let's move on.
- [Andy] Ottawahoops asks,
"how can student
athletes use social media
"to monetize their brand?"
- I'll jump in on this one.
I think the NCAA is
ridiculously difficult
to navigate.
And I have real
venom towards it.
And I don't know every detail.
I have real venom towards it
because I also grew
up in the wine business,
where the laws are
ridiculous and not practical,
and are archaic,
and then it gets even
worse when you really look
under the underbelly of
why the rules sit there.
So I think student
athletes have to be careful
because they can lose
that eligibility, right?
Like, were you
always scared like that?
It was always like
a bad cloud, right?
And Coach K was
like, "Don't fuck up!"
- Right, now, you don't
want to mess up his program.
He's not gonna like that.
But that's the thing.
The regulations and the rules,
you shouldn't be
trying to monetize yourself
because they're
gonna hit you over the head
with the suspension.
- That's why I have an answer.
What your job to do,
is to really build,
if you care about that, if
you're that entrepreneurial,
and if you're javelin
and you're in volleyball,
there's no women's
professional volleyball league
that's gonna pay your sister
the kind of money the boys made.
So if she's thinking
about the entrepreneurial level,
what you do while
you got that attention,
or, if you're the
11th guy at Indiana State
and you don't think
you're going to the NBA,
what I think when you
have that attention is,
you build a fan base.
You don't monetize it,
you build the platform.
The way to do that,
whether you're a
superstar player
or the 11th guy on
Indiana State, is to engage.
Now, if you're a
superstar player,
and you're going to Duke,
you're probably
worried about your class,
you're worried
about the program,
so you probably have less time.
If you're 11th
guy at Indiana State,
you probably have more time.
And so you've
gotta just pull levers.
But it's about engagement.
Again, I'm hot on this because
it's a Larry Bird reference,
I didn't want to use Indiana.
Like it was,
I thought it was funny.
So if you're
Indiana State, 11th guy,
every single
person that references
your game on Twitter is
something you can engage with.
Maybe you didn't play,
but it would be really
funny if Tyler was like,
"You guys sucked tonight."
And you jump in
and like, "Yo, bro."
They'd be pumped because they
actually watched that game.
That context building,
now all of sudden
you leave school
with 80,000 followers
where you would
have had maybe 1500
if you didn't give a crap.
And now all of a
sudden you are tweeting out,
looking for
opportunities this summer.
That's where
you're at your height
because you just
went through the program,
and six or seven leads come in,
and away you go.
That's really the only way
within the rules of the NCAA.
Agreed, move on.
- [Andy]Rodney.
- Rodney, Rodney Pete?
- His handle's DJ Drive.
- Do you know
who Rodney Pete is?
Just yes or no.
Do you know who Rodney Pete is?
- [Man] No.
- Rodney Pete?
- [DRock] No.
- Rodney Pete, Rodney Pete,
Rodney Pete, Rodney Pete?
Sorry, Rodney.
USC quarterback,
went to the Lions,
had a nice career.
These youngsters
don't know, Rodney.
- Maybe you should know
the Lions, come on Trick.
- [Trick] My
family's from Michigan.
- You're a big
disappointment, man.
- [Trick] I've
been through all that.
(Gary laughs)
- Let's move on.
- [Andy] Rodney asks, "What did
"the NBA teach you about
basketball that you can apply
"to marketing or
branding on social media?"
- So, the first thing they do
is they sit you
down and show you
what you can get fined for.
(Gary laughs)
But surprisingly,
a lot of the stuff,
because I was watching
what guys got in trouble for,
all that stuff created such buzz
and got them all (laughs)--
- You're like the
arbitrage was worth it, yeah.
- Too much shocked
and awe, but anyway.
To me, the best advice that
they gave us was be yourself.
Don't make every post
about a product pitch.
Right away, as soon as
you come out of the league,
or as soon as you
finish university,
then you can accept money for,
Then you can start--
- Sneakers.
- Monetizing, right.
Right away you're
gonna have people,
"Hey, tweet this.
Pitch my product.
"Whatever, I'll pay you."
- Sports cards.
- It's good and well,
but you don't
want your social media
to be flooded with that.
You just want to be
genuine, be who you are.
I think it's also good to share,
don't just reply to
tweets and whatever after wins.
Be the same person,
wins and losses.
Don't go into a whole,
depending on the situation.
- Be careful who
you're responding to and how.
- Be genuine,
be authentic, yeah,
always respond to real people.
I think there
are a lot of people
hiding behind
different accounts out there,
stuff like that.
- Yeah, Dunk. (laughs)
Kidding, I'm kidding.
Talk to me about the
biggest thing you learned
in your first season of the NBA.
Nothing to do with marketing,
just macro learning.
You know, this has
probably been on your mind
as a little kid, then
definitely got more serious
after your freshman
year of high school.
Here it is, this is it.
You're in the league.
What's the biggest
thing you learned in year one?
Kevin obviously sat down and
gave you some good advice.
You had some
good bets on that team
that you stumbled into.
- Great bets, yeah.
- Like macro.
- To me, the biggest
thing I took away is,
there's so much,
I came from a college
where there was stability.
Coach K was my coach every year,
I had, for the most part,
similar teammates every year.
The NBA and, you know, I talked
to my friends with other jobs,
there's so much turnover,
there's so much
unpredictability.
Like, I went into
practice one morning
and they said, "Hey,
GM wants to talk to you.
"Hey, you're going to Denver."
Okay, cool.
You can't
control your situation.
- I'm gonna do
that to DRock tomorrow.
I'll be like, you know what?
You've been traded to
the Chattanooga office.
But that's crazy, right?
You have to pick
up your whole life.
There's a lot of great things
that comes along
with professional sports,
and I'm sure the
veterans tell you,
once your family kicks in.
- Right.
- Your daughter loves
her school in Denver,
and now you're in Sacramento.
- Yeah, so I think
the best piece of advice
that I got from those guys,
and I watched it
happen on that first team,
is no matter what's
happening around the game,
have the same work habits,
have the same approach
to practice, to the games,
to shoot around,
to film session.
Have an approach
that you believe in,
that you can stick to--
- Everywhere.
- That's not gonna
change regardless of--
- And have you done that?
- Yeah, I have.
I mean, I'm only four years in.
- But you're on
three teams in four years.
- Three teams in four years.
Four different head coaches.
I feel like I have
found a routine
in something that I believe in
that I can continue
to grow and get better,
regardless of the situation.
- Was it easier to walk
into the Denver locker room
after experience
being the new guy
in the Portland locker room?
- Yeah, for sure.
- Was that weird and scary?
- Everything's,
I would say, unpredictable.
You don't know what to expect.
I was telling them,
well, actually, funny,
when I went into
the Denver locker room,
they started playing a rap song.
I did a rap song,
so everywhere I go
people make fun of me for it.
Which is fine,
I have fun with it.
You know, that
lightened the mood.
And also, the NBA, you
know players on every team.
- In high school, in college,
things of that nature.
- Right.
- Right, cool, Andy K?
- [Andy] Cody Wheat asks,
"What do you
think people get wrong
"about professional athletes?
"What do you think is
the biggest misconception?"
- I can tell you the
thing that bothers me the most
is when people talk about
athletes are stupid
or dumb or whatever,
and they go broke because they
don't know what they're doin'.
I don't know anybody,
all the players that
I know are still in the league,
but people have gone broke
or they've lost
what they made out of,
I could see it
happenin' more from generosity
- That's exactly right.
- Than from bad business moves
It's not--
- I'm so glad you said this,
I apologize for cutting you off.
I am stunned by that variable
as we just
recruit our first class.
You're exactly right.
It's not that
they're dumb, it's that--
- They wanna do
so much for everyone.
- Their inner circle,
and listen,
there's a lot of cliche,
lower-middle class, poor,
and it's like they wanna help.
They've been praying
to get through the
system to this moment.
Being rich you can get injured.
Coming from tough places
you could get into trouble.
I think that's
exactly right, my man.
They're tryin' to do good,
so much so, I don't
know if you've seen this,
I've already seen this,
some of these kids
have to go through the
very difficult decision
of actually
cutting off their world
because literally all
that's happening is there's,
I saw a kid with his cell phone
and in 30 minutes,
get asked for tens
of thousands of dollars
from 11 different people.
- Right.
And it happens all the time.
- And it's not,--
- I'm glad you went there man.
- People are so quick to say,
"Bad business move,
bad restaurant,
"bad this bad that."
The most generous
people I've ever met
have been teammates in
the NBA, without a doubt.
- Now, there's
also Antoine Walker,
who's out of his mind.
- Yeah.
(group laughter)
- And by the way, on that note,
I'm making that joke 'cause
I wanna give him a compliment.
What he's doing right now
for kids that are
coming out of the league,
it takes a lot of humility.
Listen, I'm sure
there's economics with it,
I don't know him but,
I'm sure he's getting paid
and it doesn't
hurt to get the money,
but he's goin'
in there and sayin'
"Look at me.
"Look what happens."
Man made hundreds
of millions of dollars.
Oof.
Andy K?
Andy felt that one.
- [Andy] Sam asks,
"How are you
able to stay positive
"when working towards
your goals and ambitions
"without seeing
improvement on a regular basis?"
- To me that's one
of the hardest things.
I think whether you do-
- What part of your
game was toughest for you,
if you said at a macro,
the thing that was hardest for
you to develop in your game,
that you can rewind to now,
we're goin' very
macro basketball now,
what would that be?
- Last summer
I wanted to change the
way in which I shot the ball,
my form and--
- Period?
- Period, yeah.
- Well that's a little crazy.
- Yeah, well it's crazy.
- It's hardcore.
- I always felt like this:
Tiger Woods broke down a
swing that had won Masters,
and then he re-worked it.
I wasn't breakin'
down a shot that works.
(laughing)
I was breakin' down a
shot that didn't work.
- I love it.
- I wanted to change my form,--
- And?
- There were a lot of
times I didn't see progress,
I got with the coach and we
were in the gym every day,
and it was frustrating,
stuff felt awkward,
you have muscle memory and
habits that are hard to break
if you've been doin'
em wrong for so long.
So that was somethin' that I
fully committed to last summer--
- And?
- Like the question said,
there were a lot
of times where you--
- But where are we right now?
- I feel very, I'm still,--
- In it.
- I'm still in it,
I'm still on that journey,
I'm very happy
with where my form is.
I hit more jump shots this year
than I have any
year in the league,
and now I feel like I have
a base and a form that I can--
- Build on top of.
- continue to improve.
- Andy, you should,
your jump shot has
been struggling lately.
Where are you
right now with your game?
- I haven't been
playing that much.
- Me neither. Dunk?
How you feelin' about yourself?
You're very athletic.
- [Dunk] I always
feel good about my game.
- Yeah but blindly.
How's the actuality of it?
- Good.
- You playing well?
Jake?
- [Dunk] I just
haven't played in a while.
- [Gary] Jake, how you doin?
- No basketball.
- [Gary] No basketball.
(laughter)
- [Dunk] I mean, if we go up
against Mase-
- Yeah listen I'll
give you a preview,
you're gonna lose.
- [Trick] Mase, you
gotta tell 'em about Yoda.
- Oh yeah, nah it's--
- Tell me.
- Like I said, I found
a shooting coach, he's--
- Yoda's the name of a
dude who's a shooting coach?
- Tell 'em why he's
called Yoda, though.
- Oh, 'cause you have to
do all sorts of weird stuff
like close your
eyes and shoot backwards
while you
elevate and eating Jello?
- No, it's just more
he's like a bald little,
you know how you get the
gray hair goin' around here.
- [Trick] He has
the record for most--
- Yeah, so he didn't have like,
there are shooting
coaches in the NBA.
- Of course.
- This guy had no NBA.
- Right, he's an
unofficial kind of Yoda.
- [Andy] He's an old,
white little Steph Curry.
- But I watched him,
and the guy he made like
1503 free throws in a row,
so I was like,
"Hey, I wanna work with you."
(laughing)
- You saw that on YouTube?
Or you were sitting
there tying your shoes
and watchin' an old white
dude hit 1503 free throws?
Just curious.
- He had the film of it.
On the spot, if
you walk into the gym
he'll rip you off 100
in a row, and I was like,
"That's so incredible."
- So awesome.
- And we call him Yoda 'cause
he's little and bald and wise.
- I love it.
- Good dude.
- Mase, I'm glad
you stopped by man.
- Thanks for havin' me.
- You get to ask
the question of the day.
You get to ask
any question you want,
macro, micro, basketball, life,
entrepreneurship, interests,
anything you want,
you'll get thousands of answers,
there might be
some good insight.
Fire away.
- Anything.
- Man.
What's the best thing to do
in New York over the summer
that people don't know about?
And don't tell me Hamilton,
'cause you can't
get tickets to that.
- Why can't you get tickets?
They pay well in the NBA.
- They do, but--
- So buy some
fuckin' tickets, Mason.
- Alright, I'll
buy some tickets.
- Okay, good.
- What's the thing to do
in New York in the summer
that people don't know about
that you just have to do,
how 'bout that?
- Love it.
My man, thanks for stoppin' by.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)